einen schönen guten abend und willkommen
bei heute live ja was bringen die
nächtlichen ausgangssperren die derzeit
in immer mehr regionen deutschlands
eingeführt werden bzw auch schon
teilweise eingeführt worden sind nützen
die denn überhaupt etwas da gehen die
meinungen auseinander
strikt dagegen jedenfalls ist der
fdp-bundestagsabgeordnete stefan thomé
warum er diese ablehnt wird er uns
gleich im interview verraten
vorher aber wollen wir uns ein bild aus
einer betroffenen stadt machen und da
brauchen wir hier in mainz gar nicht in
die weite ferne schweifen dann auch in
der rheinland pfälzischen
landeshauptstadt gilt seit heute morgen
0 uhr die sperre und die wird auch
polizeilich kontrolliert wir schalten da
jetzt zu meiner kollegin susanne genath
sie steht am rheinufer in mainz unter
euch so sander wird quasi also in einer
stunde werden die bordsteine
hochgeklappt merkt man schon was davon
und wie wird die polizei sich auf diese
situation vorbereiten
der christopher die polizei bereitet
sich vor allem auf die ausgangssperre
mit mehr präsenz vor auch hier am
rheinufer hier ist bei schönem wetter
wie heute
normalerweise partymeile und damit soll
heute schluss sein hier war tagsüber
schon ziemlich viel los das ist daneben
um 21 uhr alles zu ende und dabei hatte
meint eigentlich gehofft diese
ausgangssperre verhindern zu können und
man hatte in der tat sehr gute incidents
werte bis etwa mitte märz da lagen die
unter 50 über eine längere zeit genauso
wie in ganz rheinland pfalz dann sind
sie aber sprungartig gestiegen haben
sich teilweise verdoppelt so dass der
oberbürgermeister hier vorgestern die
ausgangssperre verfügen musste und die
muss kontrolliert werden zum einen vom
ordnungsamt und vom an zum anderen
natürlich von der polizei
und da ist jetzt renaldo roberto bei mir
sie und ihre kollegen müssen in etwa
einer stunde beginnen wir haben es
gehört
worauf sind sie eingestellt an diesem
wochenende ja wir sind darauf
eingestellt dass natürlich die regelung
noch nicht überall durchweg bekannt ist
dass die leute einfach noch nicht genau
wissen
wann beginnt die ausgangssperre oder
besteht überhaupt eine ausgangssperre es
gibt ja auch viele die von außerhalb von
mainz hierher kommen um hier am rhein
eben sich aufzuhalten abends und das
müssen wir natürlich erklären und das
wird wahrscheinlich eine der größten
aufgaben sein die meine kollegen haben
werden das ganze zu erklären wir spüren
sowieso in der letzten zeit das relativ
viel diskussionsbedarf besteht bezüglich
solcher regelungen und das werden wir
wahrscheinlich auch heute abend merken
wie sehen die regelungen denn überhaupt
aus die sind ja in den städten meistens
ähnlich wie sieht es hier in mainz aber
ja es ist tatsächlich so dass jetzt seit
vorgestern eben diese ausgangssperre
verfügt ist die gilt seit heute nacht um
0 uhr ab heute zum ersten mal ab 21 uhr
bis morgen früh um 5 uhr das heißt es
darf sich keiner ohne triftigen grund in
der stadt im stadtgebiet mainz aufhalten
das heißt alle müssen eigentlich zu
hause sein triftige gründe gibt es
verschiedene nun ist die situation ja
schwierig es gibt eine landesverordnung
es gibt eine verfügung der stadt die
ändert sich ständig wir haben jetzt die
achtzehnte glaube ich corona bekämpfung
verordnung in rheinland pfalz wo können
sich die leute denn überhaupt
informieren wie es jetzt in ihrer stadt
sein sollen ja sie sprechen da was ganz
wichtiges an es ist tatsächlich
schwierig für die leute was gilt
tatsächlich im moment aktuell aber man
kann immer wieder die informationen auf
den webseiten zum beispiel vom land
rheinland pfalz finden
corona punkt rlp.de da stehen wirklich
die neuesten informationen auch in einem
faq sehr gut erklärt und die städte
mainz als auch worms zum beispiel die
beide ausgangssperren haben haben sehr
gut auf ihren webseiten diese sachen
erklärt wie reagieren sie denn und ihre
kollegen wenn sie jetzt auf jemanden
treffen die gegen diese ausgangssperre
verfügt verstößt ist wird er eher
ermahnt wird der verband bekommt eine
strafe ja das ist genau die spannweite
in der die kollegen sich bewegen können
wir achten momentan noch so ein bisschen
drauf jetzt besteht dass er erst seit
heute nach wir achten darauf was erklärt
uns derjenige ist das nachvollziehbar
dass er das einfach nicht wissen konnte
und dann wird er dann freundlich darauf
hingewiesen und wird gebeten nach hause
zu gehen das sollte er dann auch
möglichst machen wenn wir aber das
gefühl haben er lügt uns an und er
findet irgendeine geschichte warum er
jetzt ausgerechnet heute abend noch
unterwegs sein muss und dann werden wir
natürlich die personalien aufnehmen und
leiten das bußgeldverfahren
dann über die stadt mainz auch ein meint
es ja nicht die erste stadt in rheinland
pfalz welche erfahrungen haben sie in
anderen städten gemacht haben ja schon
gesagt worms und alzey die waren ja alle
schon betroffen ja genau in worms haben
wir zum beispiel schon gemerkt dass in
den kontrollen viele jugendliche nachts
ja die diese maßnahme einfach nicht
akzeptieren wollten und dann in der
kontrolle auch aggressionen zum teil zu
tage treten sind ein hoher
diskussionsbedarf hatte ich ja vorhin
schon erwähnt bestand aber grundsätzlich
können wir diese maßnahmen schon sehr
gut durchsetzen also die erfahrung aus
den anderen städten es ist durchsetzbar
und das werden wir auch hier in mainz
machen
die polizeigewerkschaft hat jetzt gesagt
sie befürchtet ein schwieriges
wochenende weist auch darauf hin dass
polizistinnen und polizisten immer öfter
beleidigt werden ja sogar angegriffen
werden wie sehen sie das hier in mainz
ja die polizeigewerkschaft äußert sich
natürlich für eine bundesweite situation
die bundesweit aber völlig
unterschiedlich wahrgenommen werden kann
wir hier in mainz haben die erfahrung
als polizei gemacht dass die mainzer
bürger eigentlich die maßnahmen sehr
sehr gut annehmen und auch sehr sehr gut
beachten und wir sind hier als polizei
in mainz mit den bürgerinnen und bürgern
zusammen eigentlich auf einem guten weg
das einzuhalten und sie hatten selbst
gesagt bis mitte märz waren die
incidents werde auch gut jetzt gehen sie
hoch und jetzt hoffen wir einfach dass
das in mainz wieder so funktioniert wie
ich denn ihre einstellung persönlich
oder auch die ihrer kollegen halten sie
denn eine solche ausgangssperre für
sinnvoll glauben sie dass das was
bringen das müssen natürlich
wissenschaftler oder politiker
entscheiden wie diese maßnahmen sinnvoll
umgesetzt werden und ob sie tatsächlich
am ende was bringen ich kann das nicht
bewerten was wir als polizei bewerten
können ist dass sich nachts schon sehr
viele menschen gerade hier in solchen
bereichen treffen auch gegen das
alkoholverbot verstoßen und dann
natürlich eine gewisse enthemmung
eintritt gerade nachts im dunklen mit
alkohol und dann können natürlich die
abstandsregeln und das masken tragen
dann vielleicht irgendwo vergessen
werden und dann ist die
ansteckungsgefahr einfach groß wobei wir
haben ja hier in meint die sehr
spezielle situation wir gucken über den
rhein die kamera kann dass man zeiger
und da liegt wiesbaden und in wiesbaden
gibt es
eine ausgangssperre rein theoretisch
könnte man ja jetzt vermuten oder auch
befürchten dass sich auf dem anderen
rheinufer also auf der anderen seite die
leute versammeln und anfangen zu feiern
das ist durchaus möglich also wir wissen
aus der erfahrung heraus der letzten
tage dass das auch schon stattfindet das
da drüben am rheinufer genauso
besuchergruppen unterwegs sind wir
hinten mainz die inzidenz werte geben
das natürlich für wiesbaden noch nicht
her und es kann aber sein dass dann in
den nächsten tagen oder wochen dort die
wehrte sich so verändern dass vielleicht
auch andere maßnahmen getroffen werden
können das kann ich aber als polizist
natürlich nicht beurteilen
und noch zum schluss die frage es geht
wie gesagt jetzt demnächst hier los da
wir schon den ersten einsatzwagen der
hier steht und wartet was ist das so für
ein gefühl für sie und auch für ihre
kollegen haben sie das sind sie
angespannt oder glauben sie dass es eine
schwierige situation werden könnte für
sie nein anspannung ist glaube ich nicht
dabei meinen kolleginnen und kollegen
wir sind extrem routiniert mittlerweile
also wir müssen das leider seit einem
jahr machen in den verschiedenen
ausprägungen wird natürlich betrifft uns
das immer wieder
und ja klar ich glaube wir können da
sehr routiniert mit umgehen und auch
jetzt die neue variante mit
ausgangssperre werden wir gut in griff
kriegen ja vielen dank soweit herr
roberto das ist also jetzt die
sichtweise der ordnungskräfte die auf
die einhaltung der ausgangssperre achten
müssen und später sprechen wir dann auch
noch mal mit bürgerinnen und bürger die
sich an die ausgangssperre halten müssen
oder halten sollen susanne horn eine
wasseranlage angela susanne noch eine
frage weil wir gerne unsere community
immer hier mit ins boot holen alexis zum
beispiel schreibt uns über youtube was
sind denn triftige gründe vielleicht
kann das dein gesprächspartner noch mal
kurz auf streifen er hatte es für ihn
nur angedeutet ja wunderbar die frage
gebe ich gerne an sie weiter herr
roberto eine userin fragt was sind denn
triftige gründe triftige gründe gibt es
ganz verschiedene da gehört tatsächlich
auch den hund ausführen dazu soll das
sich jetzt aber nicht jeder hund
anschaffen damit er nachts eben raus
kein triftiger grund ist zum beispiel
der besuch bei den eltern also bei
verwandten ersten grades oder bei
geschwistern der
besuch ist ein triftiger grund oder die
pflege von pflegebedürftigen personen dh
dass hinfahren und das zurückfahren ist
zählt als triftiger grund auch der weg
zur arbeit und von der arbeitsstelle
wieder nach hause auch das wäre ein
triftiger grund zum beispiel also ein
triftiger grund für eine ausnahme von
der ausgangssperre
und ich glaube dass mit dem hund das
darf auch immer nur einer sein wenn ich
das richtig verstanden ja ich glaube
auch ich bin das nicht ganz aber genau
diese triftige gründe würde man zum
beispiel auf der webseite der stadt
mainz finden und die sind dort einzeln
aufgelistet
wunderbar soweit christoph nein
erstmalig vielen dank susanne bis
hierhin willkommen dann später mal danke
ja also wie gesagt es natürlich nicht
die einzige stadt in der die nächtlichen
sperren gelten auch in anderen
bundesländern ist das der fall die frage
was sie bringen die bleibt allerdings
umstritten
mein kollege an seinem stern mit
weiteren einzelheiten dazu raus in den
frühling gegen die pandemie müdigkeit
die sehnsucht nach echter normalität
doch das rausgehen wird in immer mehr
städten und kreisen eingeschränkt
nächtliche ausgangssperren zum beispiel
hier in hamburg ab morgen zwischen 21
und 5 uhr auf einer corona station und
ich finde dass die ich denke ich ganz
ehrlich das ist schwachsinnig die
meinungen sehr unterschiedlich große
studien zum nutzen von corona
ausgangssperren in deutschland gibt es
nicht messen aber kann man wie viel wir
unterwegs sind eine erkenntnis der
humboldt-uni etwa zwölf prozent der
mobilität findet zwischen 20 und 5 uhr
statt mobilität heißt in der regel auch
kontakte
es geht darum kontakte zu reduzieren
in den volumen aber auch in der struktur
das heißt man kann jetzt nicht
verschiedene modelle und datenanalysen
anschauen und es spielt eben immer noch
eine rolle dass ihr im privaten bereich
noch viele kontakte haben um kontakte
neue ansteckungen generell zu reduzieren
seien ausgangssperren ein
notfallinstrument so der experte
ein instrument mit schwächen etwa wenn
die für den abend geplanten kontakte
einfach vorverlegt werden
fest steht die mobilität ist aktuell
viel höher als in ersten shut down
anonyme mobilfunkdaten zeigen 22,5
millionen bewegungen pro tag im märz
2020 jetzt 70,8 millionen an alle sind
ja total müde und können nicht mehr
und da ist das einfach ganz natürlich
dass man sich so ganz von alleine wieder
in diesen normalzustand zurück bewegt
und deshalb sind wir auch diese riesen
unterschiede in der mobilität
unterschiedlich bleiben auch die
positionen bei den chor ohne regeln in
deutschland ja interessant ist
gesprächsthema darüber sprechen wir
jetzt mit stephan thomae er ist
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der fdp im bundestag mit wahlkreis und
büro im oberallgäu wo sie uns jetzt zu
bescheiden einen schönen guten abend
herr toni ja die frage umstritten wir
haben es gehört sie persönlich aber auch
ihre fraktion ist strikt gegen die
nächtliche ausgangssperre warum haben
tim herrmann die ausgangssperren sollen
ja kontakt einschränkungen druck setzen
das was man isst braucht man auch gerade
eben gesagt hat aber es macht einen
unterschied ob jemand einfach vor die
haustür tritt um abend wenn er von der
arbeit nach hause kommt wir haben ja
auch vernommen dass das der weg zur
arbeit von der weide triftiger grund
sein kann um noch nach 22 uhr oder vor 5
uhr sich aus dem haus gelegen wenn jetzt
jemand spät abends nach hause kommt
warum sollte es ihm nicht erlaubt sein
dann haben es noch kurz vor die tür zu
seinem lohn i und block zu drehen so zu
sagen das hört ja nicht die
kontaktzahlen das virus ist nicht
aktiver nach 22 uhr als vor 22 uhr ruht
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein
spaziergänger nach 22 uhr noch noch
kontakte hat andere person trifft die
ansteckend könnte oder von denen
angeregt werden kann ist hier geringer
als tagsüber von daher müsse man
unterscheiden wird jemand einfach noch
mal vor die haustür regierung der um den
block knapp noch frische luft ehe er sie
in seine wohnung zurück zieht oder macht
sich jemand auf den weg zur party
das geht aus einer
um eine erleichterung der kontrolle und
der leistung der kontrolle
das ist nicht wirklich ein gutes
argument für die einschränkung so
wichtige bewegungsfreiheit echte wie
eben das vor die haustür treten von
daher müsste man der polizei auch zu
traurig aber jetzt könnte sie auch zu
unterscheiden schnappte jemand noch
frische luft nach 22 uhr oder geht er
zur party um sich zu betrinken
aber generell würden sie schon auch
einsehen dass es ja darum geht eben die
kontakte zu vermeiden dass das weniger
gilt das ist nachvollziehbar wenn jemand
mit dem hund spazieren geht als wenn er
zum beispiel zu einer ja nicht nur zu
einer party will aber wir sehen ja auch
immer wieder bilder von ansammlungen
einfach im freien wo sich leute dann
doch abends zusammen finden auf einer
decke sitzen oder zusammenstehen
vielleicht doch noch ein bierchen
trinken oder ähnliches und gerade das
gilt es ja dann zu vermeiden dafür
müssten sie doch verständnis haben
das gilt aber sowohl vor 22 uhr also
nach 22 uhr zu erwarten hat mit mit der
22 uhr grenze ja nichts zu tun
ja was sie sagen ist richtig kontakt
beschränkungen führen zu erfolgen bei
der pandemie bekämpfung nur es ist keine
frage der uhrzeit sondern dass das muss
man hin zu jeder tageszeit unterbinden
denn ist daneben die inzidenz werte
angeraten erscheinen lassen das stimmt
aber in unseren breiten sagen wir mal
haben wir doch die kulturelle tradition
dass man sich dann vielleicht ab einer
gewissen uhrzeit er zusammen findet auf
wie gesagt ein kaltgetränk oder
ähnliches und das würde ja dann schon
vielleicht für die spätere uhrzeit
sprechen
aber da hat er braucht man ja immer auch
ausgeführt wenn sie nun ein zeit grenze
einführen dann für das so
ausweichbewegungen dann werden die
menschen sich im frühjahr treffen privat
und wenn weniger auf hat dann dringen
sie die menschen auch in den privaten
bereich ab wer sogar sinnvoller zu zu
testen und zur probe unter bestimmten
schutzmaßnahmen und auflagen
auch die restaurants im freien wieder
öffnen können wenn sie gerade wieder
wärmer wird um eben das abdrängen
privaten bereich wo es weniger
kontrollieren können zu vermeiden denn
entweder bleiben die leute halt dann
über nacht wenn sie jemanden treffen
wollen und infektionsgefahren noch höher
oder sie weichen von der urzeit her aus
von daher ist die die nächtliche
ausgangssperre nicht das geeignete
mittel um die pandemie zu bekämpfen
darum geht es ja eigentlich welche
maßnahmen sind wirklich geeignet sind
auch angemessen auch notwendig um die
ausgesperrten zwischen 22 und 5 uhr
erschallten nicht wirklich als geeignete
maßnahmen hätte mir wir sprechen gleich
weiter von der ausgangssperre hingegen
überzeugt zu sein scheint hamburgs
erster bürgermeister peter tschentscher
denn in der hansestadt gilt diese
maßnahme auch ab morgen und der spd
politiker hat sich dazu geäußert bei uns
im zdf spezial
die zeit ist diese strategie wirkt die
müssen wir über brücken durch
zusätzliche bremswirkung und das sind
ausgangs beschränkungen die wir
einsetzen können das ist eine
konsequente einheitliche regelung für
den einzelhandel und für die kontakt
beschränkung und die sollten jetzt
wirken damit die welle nicht zu stark
wird denn dann läuft auch die
selbsttests strategie ins leere
wir müssen wirklich jetzt die zeit bis
wir einen ausreichenden impfschutz haben
noch einmal diese letzte strecke sehr
konsequent und diszipliniert sein also
diese maßnahme sozusagen als eine in
einem paket von massnahmen zeitpunkt für
die bremse sozusagen bis genug tests und
impfstoff vorhanden sind würden sie da
widersprechen
aber sagen wir mal sagt tschentscher
sagt es ist ja was dran was wir brauchen
ist eine intelligente eine smarte
kombination von maßnahmen die wir auch
langfristig durchhalten was passiert mit
diesen strengen lockdown maßnahmen sie
können für ganz kurze zeit durchgesetzt
und ergriffen werden auch das nur mit
schwierigkeiten herbert jahrzehnten ein
spieler gesagt es gibt diskussionsbedarf
es gibt erklärungsbedarf
die menschen verstehen nicht genau was
da eigentlich gilt warum das gilt und
wenn die menschen nicht verstehen was
gilt dann ist auch die akzeptanz und die
befolgung geringer
von daher brauchen wir maßnahmen die
verstanden werden können und die auch
langfristig durchgehalten werden können
und strenge ausgangs beschränkungen
ausgangssperren jahr können sich land
dass ich durchhalten was ihnen folgen
dass sie ziehen dass zwei oder vier
wochen lang durchziehen auch ein
gewissen erfolg wahrscheinlich beide
instanzen aber dann streben die leute
sobald die maßnahmen fallen wieder nach
draußen wollen an die frische luft
wollen spazierengehen treffen wieder
leute und dann gehen die bärin tendenz
wieder nach oben sie erzeugen also eine
künstliche wellenbewegung stadt
langfristige maßnahmen durch
zu führen auch für lange zeit durch
geheilt werden können und dafür brauchen
wir intelligente kombination von impfen
plus testen plus zumutbar auch
langfristig zumutbare maßnahmen wie das
masken tragen dass abstand einhalten
hygienevorschriften das hilft auch eine
damen sind langfristige erfolge und das
muss das ziel sein nicht kurzfristige
erfolge verweisen zu können die nach
wenigen wochen dann schon wieder
einbrechen
also die langfristige strategie sagen
sie wäre eine andere
aber was auch noch ein wichtiger punkt
ist und dazu wollen wir vielleicht noch
mal professor brockmann hören es geht
eben bei dieser maßnahme so sieht er ist
nicht nur um die maßnahme an sich es
geht auch um ein zeichen es geht um
psychologie auf das aufmerksam machen
auf eine bestimmte gefahrensituation wir
wollen gerade noch mal hören was dieser
experte dazu sagt wir befinden uns in
der dritten welle
das darf man nicht unterschätzen und
wenn ausgangssperren verhängt werden ist
das auch ein signal das ist ein ernstes
sowie halt im märz vor einem jahr als
beispielsweise die em abgesagt worden
ist da hat jeder bewusst ok haben wir
erst mit einer wirklich wirklich
schweren situation und ernst zu
nehmenden situation zu tun und das hat
dann immer auch noch sekundäre effekte
das würde ich gerade nochmal aufgreifen
und das vielleicht gerade auch nochmal
grafisch ein bisschen unterstützen denn
wir haben hier auf unserer zdf.de seite
hier eine ganz interessante dazu da geht
es um die neuinfektionen in deutschland
und wie man hier sehen kann ist die
erste kleinere erhebung im letzten
frühjahr gewesen da gab es eine relativ
lange zeit über den sommer die infektion
niedrig waren und dann natürlich so
richtung weihnachten ist es dann stark
angestiegen und dann gab es einen
erneuten abwahl das war dann so im
januar februar und jetzt steigen die
zahlen seit einigen wochen noch wieder
deutlich an also was man da muss doch
sehen kann ist dass es in der tat eine
ernste situation ist und dass man ja
etwas tun muss also soweit glaube ich
sind sich alle einig sie stimmen nur
nicht darin überein dass die maßnahme
die gewählte die richtige ist entladen
satz gesagt dass etwas getan werden muss
genau das ist das was die menschen ja
bemängeln es erscheint so als würde
einfach irgendetwas getan
die regierung greift irgendwelche
maßnahmen möglichst rigide um den
eindruck zu erwecken dass das hier auch
tätig ist und die entschlossen bekämpft
das war es ja brockmann sagte ich glaube
die menschen haben schon verstanden dass
wir in der pandemie leben und das dass
die situation ernst ist und dass gewisse
massnahmen verhaltensregeln eingehalten
werden müssen das ist nicht das problem
das problem ist nur dass maßnahmen
dienen zu rigide zu sin entleert nicht
nachvollziehbar erscheinen sie nicht
befolgen und deswegen passiert genau das
gegen solche maßnahmen verstoßen wird
gerade weil die menschen durchaus
verstanden haben dass wir in einer
ernsten situation leben weil die
menschen sich eigentlich rechtmäßig
verhalten wollen verantwortungsbewusst
sind das sind die allermeisten menschen
sollte man hier die schraube nicht zu
stark an drehen
ansonsten produziert man umgehungs
strategien und das was roberto auch
sagte dass eben manche leute sich
trotzdem aktiv gegen die maßnahmen
stellen gegen sie verstoßen das werden
sie immer haben und zwar je strenger die
maßnahmen sind eben weil sie nicht
verstanden werden dass wasser findet
seinen weg und deswegen gibt es nur eine
möglichkeit nämlich den menschen
mitzunehmen diesen spirit zu erzeugen
wir müssen jetzt zusammenhalten wir
muten euch nicht mehr zu als notwendig
und das gefühl haben die menschen seit
nicht sie haben das gefühl dass man
ihnen mehr zugemutet als notwendig wäre
boiko über youtube fragt uns wieso wird
immer bzw fragt sie wieso wird immer
sofort gejammert und nach schlupflöchern
gesucht ein echter harter lockern um die
incidents zu senken und dies mit tests
dann in den griff zu halten müsste doch
im sinne der fdp seien ja aber was was
sind die geeigneten maßnahmen der die
goldene regel des rechtsstaates der
rechtsmäßigkeit grundsatz dass jeder
eingriff des staates in die rechte der
menschen es geht um berufsfreiheit es
geht um gewerbefreiheit
niederlassungsleiter reise reihe die
allgemeinen freiheitsrechte muss immer
geeignet notwendig und angemessen sein
dann bin ich auch dafür wenn maßnahmen
geeignet notwendig angemessen also
rechtmäßig sind dann würde ich sie
bejahen
aber es gibt ja neben den
gesundheitlichen risiken der pandemie
auch die nebenfolgen wirtschaftliche
pädagogische psychosoziale das muss man
einbeziehen und das ich muss ein
ausgewogenes verhältnis finden denn
ansonsten müsste man für möglichst lange
zeit das ganze land in ein künstliches
koma versetzen von der nordsee zu den
alpen und vom rhein bis zur oder und das
ist langfristig nicht durchzuhalten es
kommt darauf an genau herauszufinden wo
liegen eigentlich infektionsrisiken
haben wir ein ein cluster ein bestimmter
einrichtungen in eine gemeinde wo das
wirklich lässig darauf kommt es an
möglichst punktgenaue geeignete
angemessen anatomisches mäßige maßen ist
deutlich geworden da sprach noch mal der
jurist aus ihnen der sieger aussehen
es ging um die verhältnismäßigkeit danke
bis hierhin wir sprechen gleich nochmal
weiter willkommen aber nochmal zurück
nach mainz zu meiner kollegin susanne
gehörte immer noch am rhein unterwegs
ist diesmal mit maske denn sie wollte
noch mal ein faschist innen für unsere
sammeln von betroffenen menschen
bist du fündig geworden zu sein maske
tragen weil das sehr nahe am rheinufer
ist und das ist jetzt tatsächlich noch
eine junge leute gefunden die eigentlich
wird's bald nach hause müssen und uns
aber jetzt nochmal erzählen möchten was
sie von dieser ausgangssperre heute in
mainz zum ersten mal die drastische
maßnahme seit panini beginn was was sie
davon halten
also ich finde es schwierig als junge
personen also ich bin halt studierende
hat wirklich sehr viel zu tun
im studium und habe von morgens bis
abends ab juni und dann das ist man
manchmal punkt wo man einfach sagt okay
jetzt mal kurz rausgehen bisschen die
die natur genießen und auch ein bisschen
mal was anderes machen außer uni und
dann das ist schwierig zu sagen okay ich
habe jetzt auch eine halbe stunde gehe
ich jetzt mach mit dem stress und kommen
dann eigentlich auch nicht wirklich
runter weil weil ich ja die zeit gar
nicht ob so ein bisschen runterkommen
und wie ist es bei ihnen was glauben sie
ja also ich kann es komplett
nachvollziehen dass alle maßnahmen
werden aber ich lese auch so weil man
hat heute 17 18 uhr irgendwie mit der
uni zu tun und dann will man halt
eigentlich auch mal spazieren gehen und
vor allem wenn man sich an die maßnahmen
hält und so das ist schwer aber es ist
also ich ganz verstehen weil es muss ja
also so der nicht willkürlich
entschlossen das glauben sie feiern die
leute dann nicht einfach irgendwo anders
weiter weil diese weise vielleicht
einfach aus ja klar also wenn man dann
die innenstadt meiden muss dann werden
glaube ich fiele dann eher aus zu hause
beim ausweichen muss man schauen ob das
dann überhaupt noch kann form ist ich
weiß nicht ob das dann so viel mehr
bringt war ja schon die höchsten
infektion auch im privaten bereich dann
entstehen dadurch dass er mit weniger
abstand gehalten wird keine masse
getragen wird
also das wird dann schon weniger ernst
genommen so zu sagen wenn man dass du
mich in der öffentlichkeit macht also
ich denke es wäre dann vielleicht sogar
sinnvoller wenn die leute sich dann
draußen eher sehen aber ich meine wie
schon gesagt wurde das kommt ja nicht
von irgendwo und man muss auf jeden fall
die zargen der unterkriegen und wenn das
eine maßnahme dafür ist dann denke ich
haben wir schon genügend schlaue leute
oder köpf sich zusammengesetzt das dann
zu beschließen
also ich meine wir haben jetzt schon
sehr viel insgesamt mitgemacht auch eben
als junge person
es ist ein bisschen nervig wenn es dann
immer heißt ja nur noch ein bisschen und
nur noch ein bisschen und das dann
nämlich ganze funktioniert und ja ich
denke mal das werden wir auch noch
durchhalten und wir hoffen jetzt ein
bisschen noch auf die impfkampagne dass
das vielleicht irgendwann mal noch
funktioniert und eben nicht so wie
bisher läuft und genau dann denke ich
wenn das die meisten schon ertragen bzw
hatten nicht viel war also
punkte kontrapunkt jetzt wahrscheinlich
schnell ab nach hause
dank noch mit ihm sprechen können
vielen dank ist zusammengehen hat mit
unseren eindrücken vom rheinufer alles
gute für dich und danke schön dass du
heute abend unterwegs war so und
vielleicht noch ein kurzer hinweis an
die community
ich habe hier den auftrag darauf
hinzuweisen dass ein freundlicher
umgangston bei uns erbeten wird also wer
hier zitiert werden möchte er möglichst
sich dann bitte auch um einen solchen
bemühen
wir sehen im hintergrund immer noch
stefan thomé wir sprechen gleich weiter
ich würde gerne noch kurz auf einen
anderen aspekt eingehen denn es ist ja
doch relativ auffällig wie
unterschiedlich die regelungen
ausgestaltet werden in den einzelnen
bundesländern obwohl man sich ja
eigentlich beim letzten bund ländern
fiel auf ein einheitliches vorgehen
geeinigt
einzelheiten zu dieser problematik von
meinem kollegen jonas tisch am 22 märz
hatten bund und länder vereinbart in
gebieten mit einer sieben tage incidents
von mehr als 100 schafe corona maßnahmen
einzuführen
dies könnten insbesondere auch ausgangs
beschränkungen seien hieß es in dem
beschluss
doch die einzelnen bundesländer setzen
den sehr unterschiedlich um
in einigen ländern werden auf einer
inzidenz von 100 ausgangs beschränkungen
entweder verpflichtend umgesetzt oder
nach der entscheidung der örtlichen
behörden ersteres gilt etwa in bayern
letzteres in rheinland pfalz in vier
bundesländern können die örtlichen
behörden erster bei einer inzidenz von
200 ausgangs beschränkungen verhängen
hessen ist ein sonderfall hier können
kreise und kommunen auch schon bei
geringeren fallzahlen ausgangs
beschränkungen beschließen wenn etwa die
krankenhausbetten ausgelastet sind
hamburg hat unabhängig von einem
bestimmten schwellenwert ausgangs
beschränkungen beschlossen
brandenburg verhängt ausgangs
beschränkungen für fast alle landkreise
nur an den ostertagen in vier
bundesländern gibt es keine
einheitlichen regeln zur ausgangssperren
in nordrhein westfalen hat
beispielsweise nur der landkreis
minden-lübbecke eine verhängt obwohl
viele städte und landkreise in nrw
über einer inzidenz von 100 liegen die
eigentliche gemeinsamen beschlüsse von
bund und ländern werden also recht
unterschiedlich angewandt
tja die beschlüsse werden recht
unterschiedlich angewandt darf ich
gerade bei ihnen noch mal nachfragen
herr toni wie ist es denn bei ihnen im
wahlkreis sind in bayern gilt die regel
dass wenn die sieben tage incidents
länger als drei tage in folge über 100
liegt dann gelten diese ausgangssperren
von 22 bis 5 uhr
das gilt für meinen wahlkreis auch
sowohl in der kreisfreien stadt kempten
aus dem landkreis oberallgäu also im
landkreis lindau gegen die instanzen
die sind drei sätzen seit mehr als drei
tagen über 100 ja also wir haben ja
gerade im beitrag gesehen dass da ein
ziemlicher flickenteppich entstanden ist
in deutschland wie stehen sie dazu
halten sie es für sinnvoll dass regional
unterschiedliche maßnahmen dann auch
ergriffen werden können während sie für
mehr einheitlichkeit wie es der ihre
position
ja diese ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
sollen ja die einheitlichkeit herstellen
das wäre natürlich wünschenswert dass
das sind das ist auch nachvollziehbar
in ganz deutschland überall die gleichen
regeln gelten dass es dann zu ziehen
durch den folgen kommt das hat einfach
die meditations- geschehen zu tun aber
es wäre natürlich sehr gut wenn die
bundesländer sich darauf verständigen
könnten dass sie die regeln einheitlich
anwenden noch besser wäre es wenn wenn
der bund da wo in die
gesetzgebungskompetenz zufällt durch
gesetze im parlament beschlossen werden
und die auch öffentlich debattiert
werden beraten werden
im play-off deutschen bundestages diese
regeln schaffen würde
diese möglichkeit gibt es durchaus und
müsste davon gebrauch machen und dann
müsste der bundestag ein solches gesetz
beschließen und dann würden dort im
bundestag argumente und gegenargumente
meinung und gegenmeinung die klingen
kreuzen aufeinanderprallen und den
vollen scheinwerferlicht der
öffentlichkeit würden dann neben die
gesichtspunkte die für und gegen diverse
maßnahmen sprechen ausgetragen werden
und da höre ich jetzt sogar aushält ohne
dass sie das gefühl haben als
bundestagsabgeordneter in der jetzigen
form nicht ausreichend einfluss nehmen
zu können auf die gestaltung die
koalition die große koalition hat der
regierung
[Musik]
mit reichende verordnungsermächtigungen
erteilt das heißt die regierung kann die
verordnungsermächtigung durch
rechtsverordnung regieren
viele viele kompetenzen sind bei den
ländern verblieb und auch entsteht so
diese haben dieser eindruck dass hinter
verschlossenen türen zuletzt es
buchstäblich einer nacht und nebelaktion
regeln ausgehandelt werden in einem jahr
schwer nachvollziehbaren intransparenten
aushandlungsprozess und besser wäre es
so was würde in der öffentlichkeit
debattiert werden
auch ein parlament macht fehler es gibt
auch keine richtigkeit gewehr im
deutschen bundestag natürlich nicht wenn
man will dass politik von menschen
gemacht wird und nicht von maschinen
dann dann wird es zu federn kann aber so
ein parlament ist doch auch ein gewisser
qualitäts sicherungsmechanismus allein
schon weil die opposition klar ihre
rolle versucht die schwachstellen
regierungsvorlagen zu finden kommt ihm
auch gesichtspunkte zur sprache wo
vielleicht unwirksame maßnahmen
ergriffen werden sollen
das wäre viel viel besser wenn wir diese
maßnahmen im parlament in aller
öffentlichkeit debattieren würden und
sie in den medien dann öffentliche
diskussion anzetteln können also die
fehlende beteiligung des parlaments
einer in den letzten tagen oft gehörte
kritik auch von ihnen gerade noch mal
geäußert stephan thomae war das
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der fdp im bundestag eine letzte frage
habe ich noch wie verbringen sie ostern
werden sie viel unterwegs sein
wir werden alle einem einen test machen
und dann gucken mit wem wir uns treffen
können so weit ist die die vorschriften
zu lassen und dann werden wir gucken
dass wir möglichst in der familie feiern
können wir bleiben logo weist zwar hause
wohin man auch hinfahren zu sein
das ist in der tat eine berechtigte
frage vielen dank dass sie sich die zeit
für uns heute abend genommen haben
stephan thome von der fdp
dankeschön und liebe grüße ins allgäu ja
und auch an euch vielen dank fürs
zuschauen für die kommentare bzw
naja für die die den ton an doch
getroffen haben und die fragen die wir
auch besprochen haben
wir hoffen es hat euch etwas gebracht
und wünschen euch natürlich ein frohes
osterfest erst mal einen schönen abend
und dann schöne feiertage bis zum
nächsten live stream
bis also ganz bald